Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Hello and welcome to another episode of
What's Up Prof.
>> Hello, Walter.
>> Silence.
>> I wanted to give you the honors. I I
ignored you.
>> We'll get We'll have to do a bit of an
ignoring in the future as well.
>> What if we both ignore each other for
half an hour, man? Who's going to start
the what's up Prof then?
>> I don't know. I I we I don't think we
any of us like silence that much.
>> Okay. All right. Okay.
>> Well,
>> so
what do you want to tell the people?
First I want to just tell them this is
very close to the Melbourne outreach. Um
there's a bit of confusion but just to
make it clear people can come uh day
visitors. They don't have to register.
It's only when you want to have some
food that you have to register and if
you want to stay over but yeah all are
welcome.
>> Otherwise any day visitor can come
>> bring people bring visitors.
>> We'll break down some walls and smash
out some windows and make space. No
problem.
>> No problem.
>> Okay. And we'll bring a sledgehammer.
>> Yes.
>> Hand luggage.
>> And then also there's uh that um small
uh outreach in Malan Bumbi. I think
that's how you pronounce it near
Brisbane. Um and that's also but that
one also people have to register for. So
that's just the short of that
>> or the long and the short of that.
>> And the long and the short of that.
>> Okay. But before we can talk about this,
let's pray.
Our heavenly father, we are thankful to
be in your um service and we ask that
you enlighten our minds in this
discussion and help us in Jesus name.
Amen.
>> Amen.
You know what, Martin? There's nothing
more irritating
than someone who says that they have
eaten the truth by the spoonfuls and
everybody else is ignorant.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Or this is the true church and that is
the false one. Then everybody is up in
arms immediately, isn't it? So
>> that's true. Because you always believe
that you're in the wherever you are, you
are in the truth.
>> In the truth. Now all of us have been
through this process
and the the problem is or let's not say
the problem, the solution is in the
scriptures
>> and you have to follow what the
scriptures say.
And basically it's a battle between
opinions and scripture
or put it another way tradition between
uh traditions and scriptures
>> or put it another way creeds and
scriptures.
>> Mhm.
>> And eventually one must make a decision.
Now we've given many series in the past
where we show that uh these these
conflicts between creeds
and scriptures have been ongoing for
2,000 years. And everybody every time
somebody discovers something new in the
scriptures,
there is turmoil and a separation
from those that don't want to abolish
the creed and stick to it and those that
recognize that the Bible asks for some
change.
And so, how many denominations do we
have in the world? Thousands of them.
because everybody sees another little
portion that the others reject
and then they move along by themselves
and you have a new organization.
So you move from a church of England.
Eventually you move on and you have
Puritans.
Then you move on and you have uh
Baptists and you move on and you have
Methodists and you move on and you have
congregationalists and you it just goes
on and on and on and on and on.
Eventually you have evangelicals
and then you have a whole plethora of
what we call confusion.
>> Yeah, that's it. Yeah, Babylonian
confusion event.
>> Okay. Now, what if you gathered all of
those gems of truth that people were not
only willing to fight for, separate for,
or even die for,
and put them into one package
and ask yourself the question, is it
truth?
So when we talk about the third Elijah
then it is a message that is scriptural
and we must understand that
>> and therefore it is not something that
we invented.
In fact, Martin, I think you can
probably agree with me that it's not
only something we didn't invent, but
something that we had to wrestle with in
our own lives and make a decision
whether we're going to stick to creeds
or whether we're going to go along with
what the word says.
>> Yeah, it's it's a challenge. It's
definitely a personal challenge.
>> Okay. Did we ever invent it? No. Can we
take any credit for it? No. No. Can we
proclaim it?
>> Definitely.
>> Okay. So, let's talk about the third
Elijah.
Now, on our back screen here, I think uh
Henry did a good job. Don't you think
so?
>> Definitely.
>> I I quite like this.
>> You have the entire conflict. There's a
there's a king.
There's a woman.
Uh there's something interesting about
the woman, right? And there's a mount
that is Carmel. There's an altar.
There's a prophet. There's fire from
heaven.
And there are people that are listening
and are at the point of decision making.
>> Isn't that what you see on the back
there?
And so there have been a number of
Elijah
throughout the ages and each one
required a point of decision.
>> Yeah, that's
>> it's biblical.
>> Definitely. It will be the same at the
end.
>> Okay. So, who are the role players here
in this backdrop? Well, there's the
prophet.
>> Yeah.
>> There's the people.
There's the kings.
And there's the women
>> meaning the churches, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So, let's look at the third Elijah.
>> Well, before we can look at the third
one, we must first know who the first
and the second were, right? Otherwise,
there's no point in it.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So the first Elijah,
he stands for the law because he
confronts Ahab and Ahab calls him the
troubler of Israel.
>> And Elijah tells him, I'm not the
troubler of Israel. You are the troubler
of Israel because you have neglected the
commandments of the Lord. So there's a
confrontation with the law.
>> So there's a conflict with the kings
>> and then he has a conflict with a woman
by the name of Jezebel. We pick that
woman up in Revelation as well.
>> Yeah.
>> Where she is described as someone who
leads God's people into sun worship.
>> Excellent.
>> Okay.
And he then exposes the false worship.
So this is the job of the first Elijah.
He's confronting the kings and the
governmental systems because they are
transgressing God's law. He's
confronting religious systems that bring
in sun worship and disguise it as
Jehovah worship but in actual fact it's
Baal worship.
>> And he thereby exposes false worship.
He also did a few other things. He
resurrected the dead.
>> Mhm.
>> He trained people in the schools of the
prophets.
So he had a teaching capacity.
And he also had to flee for his life.
>> Yeah. He had to flee for his life.
Now
he discerns the voice of God from the
noise around him.
>> Yeah. Because there's a lot of people
that said this is the truth.
>> This is the truth. and you are the
troubler of Israel. And he doesn't have
an easy time. He sits in the wilderness
most of the time being sustained by God
while everybody is angry with him.
And then the the amazing thing about
him, he's translated without seeing
death.
>> He's also the one who appears with Moses
on the mount of transfiguration.
And he serves as a type of those that
will not see death at the end of time.
>> Yeah.
>> And Moses serves as the one who saw
death and was resurrected.
So basically that stands for the law and
the prophets, right?
>> Yeah.
>> His message is emulated by a second
Elijah.
So the disciples asked Jesus about this
issue and he tells them that the Elijah
that was to come has already come and
then the scriptures tell us ahuh they
discerned that he was talking about John
the Baptist.
>> Yeah.
>> Now of course John the Baptist isn't
Elijah but he had a similar message.
>> It's an antitype.
>> Yes. A typological
message.
>> Yeah. emulating
parts of the first Elijah.
But there's some differences.
>> The second Elijah is not translated
without seeing death. He dies at the
hand of the king. Actually, at the
instigation of Jezebel.
>> Yes. Of the woman.
>> Yes. And then there must come a third
Elijah to follow so that type can meet
antitype.
I will send you the prophet Elijah
before the great and terrible day of the
Lord. So that must be just before the
coming of Christ. So the message must be
repeated seems at three stages in
history.
So let's look at the second Elijah.
He's from the lineage of Zadok cousin to
Jesus. Jesus, a Judean,
uh,
gives the message that this one was to
make straight the way. He upholds the
law.
>> Mhm.
>> He condemns hypocrisy.
Do you agree with that?
>> Yeah, definitely. He showed them out.
>> He condemns false teachings.
He confronts
the church leaders.
>> Yeah. Yeah. The straight up
>> hypocrites, what are you doing here?
That's not a nice thing to say.
No.
And he points to Christ and says, "He
must increase and I must decrease." So,
he's Christ centered.
He has a plant-based diet.
>> He eats carob and wild honey.
So, he's a forerunner of Christian
martyrs.
>> Yeah.
He has a conflict with two women.
>> So there's something that happened here.
Now the first Elijah had a conflict with
one woman.
>> Yeah.
>> This one has a conflict with two women,
namely a mother and a daughter.
>> Now the mother is the one that instructs
the daughter.
>> Yeah.
>> That's interesting. And if you go to
Revelation, there is a mother that
claims that she has daughters.
There's no coincidence.
>> She's the one that seems to be in the
pound seats and instructs the daughter
as to what her wishes are.
>> So the mother tells the daughter to ask
the king for the head of John the
Baptist.
>> So this second Elijah is going to have a
tough time because some daughter church
is going to ask on behalf of a mother
church. m
>> the kings of the world to get rid of
this Elijah.
>> Yeah.
>> And the conflict costs him his life.
Now, fortunately, there's a third
Elijah.
>> So, what about the third Elijah? The
third Elijah is to come just before the
day of the Lord.
Malachi 4:5.
And the dreadful day of the Lord. And he
shall turn the hearts of the fathers to
the children and the hearts of the
children to their fathers. So let's just
stop there. What's what's his mission?
To take them back to something original.
>> Mhm. Yeah, that's true.
>> What the fathers taught.
>> And it's also a reconciliation.
>> And a reconciliation,
but you have to go back to what the
father stood for.
>> Yeah. The roots. So obviously somebody
has moved away from what the father
stood for. So he's going to bring this
about lest I come and smite the earth
with a curse. In other words, they've
moved so far away from the original
truth handed over to the disciples
that if there is not a correction, you
will fall under this curse.
>> Is that what it says?
>> It's 100% what it says. So you'll fall
under all the curse that will be on this
woman.
>> Yes.
>> That's going to be destroyed.
>> And what happened to the first woman in
the first Elijah?
>> Mhm. Eaten up by the dogs.
>> She was thrown out of a
>> a window.
>> Interesting. She was thrown out of a
high tower.
>> Yeah.
>> In other words, she had a position of
overseeing the whole world.
>> But she fell from that high position.
>> Yeah.
And then she was dead
and the dogs came and licked the blood
and then ate her and there were three
little portions that were left namely
the head, the hands and the feet. That
was all. The rest was gone.
Interesting. when uh the statue
of Baal was before the ark or the Dagon,
the fish god of the Philistines
>> that also fell before the ark which is
the law of God.
>> Mhm.
>> And there were three little pieces.
There was the head, there were the
hands, and then there was the stump with
the feet.
>> Interesting.
>> Interesting. So, there's some
interesting parallels here in the Bible.
So let's remember that the first Elijah
prophesied in the days of Ahab and
Jezebel.
Ahab was the worst king of all the kings
of Israel. It wasn't the worst one. And
he was in alliance with a wicked woman
Jezebel who enticed the children of
Israel into sun worship.
>> So this serves as a type for the final
Elijah. All of these conflicts will be
present when the final Elijah
>> does his sermonizing.
So after the invitation to the wedding
supper was sent to the churches.
Now we'll have to deal with that in
another lecture.
And they rejected the message and
therefore fell like Israel of old.
The remnant which is clearly defined as
those in Revelation 12 verse 17
>> keep the commandments and have the
testimony.
They were raised up to preach a very
peculiar message which is very similar
to that of the first Elijah.
So they're going to confront kings.
>> Mhm. They're going to confront churches
or a church and they're going to
confront the daughters of that church.
>> And the daughters are going to get very
upset and the daughters will probably
accuse this group of people
to the kings. And the kings will
eventually will make laws that if these
people don't stop, they will not be able
to buy or sell. And if they continue on
their trajectory, they're going to get a
death sentence.
>> Yeah. That's what happened then. And
>> it happened to the second Elijah.
>> Yeah.
>> So, they're going to go through a
similar experience.
Fortunately, the first Elijah was
translated. Mhm.
>> That doesn't mean that some of the
second or third Elijah won't suffer the
consequences of John the Baptist, but uh
the possibility is there that the
consequences of the first Elijah can
apply to them and that some will be
translated without seeing death.
>> So, it's actually beautiful. Both these
Elijah give a good example for the third
Elijah. What to expect?
>> What to expect. It's going to be pretty
tumultuous. So let's see what they can
expect. What must they do? Well, they
must do what the second Elijah also did
was to make straight the way for the
Lord.
In other words, they have a message that
the Messiah's coming
>> or the second coming because the second
Elijah's job was to preach about the
first coming.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> So, this Elijah must preach about the
second coming. And obviously the road is
not very straight. It's all over the
place.
>> Exactly.
>> He's got to fix it.
>> Mhm.
>> This road means the road to truth and to
heaven, right? He's got to fix it.
>> He's got to repair the old waste places.
That means there are that's Isaiah
chapter 58. The whole job of the remnant
is described there.
>> All right. So obviously
uh some of the truths have been
discarded or lying by the wayside have
been distorted. The building is pretty
crooked and skewed. So it has to be
fixed and they have a very specific
message that they have to bring in order
to accomplish this. And this is called
the three angels messages
>> and it's in Revelation chapter 14. Okay.
So we have a conflict
with women.
>> We have a conflict of ideologies.
We have a conflict in terms of who's
going to rule Christ who is coming or
the church that is staying behind.
>> And there's a very specific message
which deals with the law in particular.
That's what the first Elijah did.
>> Yeah.
And then they have to expose the great
controversy between Christ and Satan and
the bride of Christ and the synagogue of
Satan.
That's quite a mouthful, right?
>> It's a it's a tall order.
>> It's a tall order. And uh was John the
Baptist very popular when he addressed
some of these issues with the Pharisees?
>> No. Because the thing is this is also
addressing your own people.
>> What did he call the leaders of the
church? You brood of what?
>> Viper.
Martin,
>> imagine if he had to do that today.
>> I think he should go to a diplomacy
class.
That That was pretty straight. Then they
have to restore the Sabbath.
>> That's what Isaiah chapter 58 tells us.
>> Definitely. And the the first Elijah had
to restore that portion. Very good.
Well,
>> okay. The second Elijah had the
situation where the church had
was keeping the Sabbath but had
ritualized it.
>> Exactly. So they
>> So Jesus had to come and restore the
essence of the Sabbath. So the third
Elijah
must also restore the essence of the
Sabbath,
>> must exalt the law
>> because they keep the commandments. And
basically according to revelation 22
that if you don't keep them you don't
have access to the tree of life. So it's
pretty serious issue.
>> And then they also have the testimony of
Jesus. So this is a tall order by the
way. Testimony of Jesus is the spirit of
prophecy.
>> Did the first Elijah have a prophetic
role?
>> Yes. Did the second Elijah have a
prophetic role?
>> Absolutely.
>> Must the third Elijah therefore have a
prophetic role?
>> Yes.
>> It's the the prophetic gift cannot be
absent in any of the
>> in any of those three. All right. And
then they come into conflict with a
mother and she's the wife of the king.
In other words, they have a union
>> and there's a daughter who is involved
who likes dancing.
>> Isn't that surprising?
>> She's very attractive and she likes
dancing.
And they all had to face a church and
state union. All of them. Right. The
king
>> Yeah. in Israel.
He is the one who through Jeroboam and
his entire lineage
set up a false system of worship
>> and propagated it and sustained it with
the power of the state.
>> Yeah.
>> That's why there was a confrontation
with the king. So, we're going to have
the same thing in the final.
>> Even John the Baptist had the same
problem. You had the king and the mother
and daughter that gave the and he the
king was the one that executed.
>> In all these cases, the king is the one
who gave the commands instructed by the
woman.
>> Ahab danced to the tune of of Jezebel.
>> Yeah.
>> Herod as well.
>> Exactly the same. So, let's just jump to
Isaiah 58 to make sure that this is
true. Cry aloud,
>> spare not. Did the second Elijah spare
the feelings of the Pharisees?
>> No, not at all.
>> No, he didn't. Lift up thy voice like a
trumpet. So, this is not something that
happens somewhere in a corner, right?
>> All Yeah.
>> Show my people their transgressions.
>> So, all of this restoring that has to be
done has to do with their departure from
the truth.
And the house of Jacob their sins. Sin
is what?
>> Transgression of the law.
>> Transgression of the law. Verse 12 says,
"And they that shall be of thee shall
build the old waste places." We've just
said that. Thou shalt raise up the
foundations of many generations. In
other words, the truth has been trampled
on. And the most important thing here,
Martin, other foundation can no one lay
than that which has been laid.
>> That's Jesus.
>> Christ. Yeah. So the position and the
role of Christ has been trampled upon.
>> Yeah.
>> And thou shalt be called the repairers
of the breach. There's a breach in the
wall. The wall stands for the law. The
restorer of paths to dwell in. So here
is the way walking in it.
And then what in particular is he
referring to? Well, this is typical of
Hebrew writing. He explains it in the
next verse. lest you stumble and fumble
your way through it. If thou turn thy
foot from the Sabbath, from doing thy
pleasure on my holy day, and call the
Sabbath a delight, the holy of the Lord,
honorable, and shall honor it, not doing
thine own ways, nor finding thine own
pleasure, nor speaking thine own words,
then
>> so this is the
>> that's the issue.
>> Yeah. And the condition uh the there's a
condition to have the prospering. And
who is this addressed to?
>> God.
>> Those that will come out of you. That's
the remnant.
>> Then shalt thou delight thyelves in the
Lord, and I will call cause thee to rise
upon the high places of the earth. You
will be the head and not the tail.
And feed thee with the heritage of Jacob
thy father. What's the heritage of Jacob
thy father? Eternal life.
>> Yeah.
>> For the mouth of the Lord has spoken it.
Okay. So this is part of the job of the
Elijah refer them back to the
commandments
and uh come back into harmony
>> right so very important they have to
preach the law and the testimony
testimony is the spirit of prophecy
>> it doesn't go there's no separation ever
so the law is the books of Moses which
include the ten commandments
and what the prophet said both of them.
>> Well, I was just thinking if it's
church and state, if it's a state you in
in on earth implementing this, it's
wrong because then it's church and
state. In the Bible, those two together,
law and testimony, is absolutely
necessary.
>> Yes. But you're talking about biblical
law.
>> That's it. It's not enforced by humans.
>> No,
>> this is God's
>> interesting in in ancient Israel, the
king was a type of Christ.
>> Well, before that, the king was Christ.
He when it was a theocracy,
>> yes,
>> then there wouldn't wouldn't have been
any any any problem with
>> chose an earthly one and that's where
the problem came in. So that diadem has
to go and Christ has to be the real
lawgiver eventually again. Yes, we're
going to talk about that because this
diadem, this ruling power is actually
currently a system of ruling over evil
rather than controlling good. Duff, you
know, it's actually again the church
state combination on earth for by humans
is a reversal of Satan of the true one
that God is.
>> Correct. All right. Isaiah 8:20 is the
very famous text in this regard to the
law to the testimony. And if they don't
speak according to this word, it is
because there is no light in them.
And who is the light? The light is
Christ. Right? So both the law and the
testimony must be in harmony with what
Christ says. Proverbs 28 verse9 says,
"He that turneth away his ear from
hearing the law,
even his prayer shall be an
abomination." That's a powerful verse.
>> I wonder if people really contemplate
how serious that is.
>> That's very serious.
Daniel 9:13, "As it is written in the
law of Moses, all this evil is come upon
us, yet made we not our prayer before
the Lord our God, that we might turn
from our iniquities and understand thy
truth."
So if you turn your foot from the law,
then you are in darkness and you don't
understand the truth.
>> That's interesting. So you must be in
harmony with the law of God in order to
understand truth.
>> Yeah.
So can we say that as in the days of
Israel if they obeyed the testimonies
they were blessed and if they turned
their backs on them they suffered
consequences.
>> Definitely the Bible tells us the the
whole story of Israel. That's it.
>> Okay.
The remnant follows the prophetic
pattern
and if it despises the council of the
prophets it suffers the same
consequences as did Israel of old. So
this remnant, is it so pure and so
perfect that it never puts a foot wrong?
>> No.
>> On the contrary, it's described as a
pretty feeble bunch. Poor, pitiful,
blind, naked. It's not a very good
description.
>> No.
>> Okay. So, this is not blowing your
trumpet.
>> It's not be Yeah. Exactly. It's not um
being boastful. Oh, we are ludicia.
>> Yes. No, no, no. You're not very proud
of being Lodia. You know the truth,
but the execution of the truth is a bit
of a problem. All right. So, can we pray
as did David, the sweet singer of
Israel, incline my heart unto thy
testimonies?
Make make me, you know, come into one
accord with the testimonies.
Then shall we be able to testify with
him. Thy testimonies have I taken as a
heritage forever.
I have kept. Thy testimonies. Oh,
Martin, this is always the problem.
There's a big difference between hearing
and doing.
>> Yeah.
>> Thy testimonies also are my delight and
my counselors. Well, I sit in some
church meetings where I I can just
wonder and say, "Well, they they're
certainly not a delight in this
congregation or in part parts of it.
Thy testimonies are my meditation."
>> Does that mean you must study them?
>> I'm contemplating, reading them.
>> I have rejoiced in the way of thy
testimonies.
>> Therefore, I love thy testimonies.
Well, if we can get to that point
>> exactly,
>> it'll be great, right?
>> Be fine.
>> And we shall know to the fullest extent
what the promise of the Lord means when
he says, "Blessed are they that keep his
testimonies and that seek him with a
whole heart."
>> Yeah.
>> Israel of old was very good at keeping
the testimonies, right?
No, they were a very good example of
what it what happens when you don't do
it.
>> Okay. And the remnant are also very good
at keeping the testimonies, right?
>> No, unfortunately it's the same.
>> No.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> You see, you mentioned in in the
beginning that we also had to go through
quite a bit. And when you first read the
testimonies, was it, oh, wonderful. Now
I can just quickly get into harmony with
it. was more like oops.
>> Exactly. But it depends on your
attitude. Lord, show me please help me.
>> Once you have actually eaten them and
incorporated them, then they become a
delight.
>> Yeah.
>> But once you just read them and confront
them, they become a disaster.
>> So the question modern is does God have
a church?
>> Definitely. Is it comprised of thousands
of broken up units? Each one with a
portion of truth?
>> No.
>> Like a puzzle that you have to put
together?
>> No. That's not how God works.
>> Okay. So, let's say he has a truth. Is
it any better than the Israel of old?
>> No.
>> No. Because no church has ever become
better than the Israel of old. They
might have had more truth, but they're
not better. They're just as rebellious.
Well, in this case, they're probably
worse.
>> So, let's read a statement from
testimonies for the church. God in mercy
called them out of the Egyptians that
they might worship him without hindrance
or restraint. He wrought for them in the
way by miracles. He proved and tried
them by bringing them into straight
places. And after the wonderful dealings
of God with them and their deliverance
so many times they
murmured
>> murmured
when tried or proved by him. Their
language was would to God we had died by
the hand of the Lord in the land of
Egypt. They lusted for the leaks and the
onions there said the angel ye have done
worse than they.
So we're not better
but salvation was from the Jews. They
knew that the Messiah was coming. They
didn't accept him, but they knew he was
coming.
So, he has defined his people throughout
the ages. And he has clearly defined the
attributes of the last representatives.
They keep the commandments. They have
the testimony and they preach the three
angels messages.
>> That's it. You have to.
>> It doesn't say they're perfect in doing
this. And it doesn't say that only one
of these you can only keep the
commandments or you only have to test.
It's a package.
>> Correct. All right. Let's ask some more
questions. Does he have other children
beside this group?
>> Yes. Mhm.
>> Yes. Besides the group that preaches the
this three angels messages that keep the
commandments and held and hold to the
testimony, does he have others? The
answer is obviously yes.
>> He has children but not a church. not
other churches.
>> Okay, that's why the question is phrased
carefully. Does he have other children?
The answer is obviously yes. But what
are they called to do? They are called
to sever their connection with the
institutes that they are in because they
are admonished to come out of her. My
people,
my people obviously means his people
that are in institutions that he doesn't
want them in
>> called Babylon.
So to what message are they supposed to
respond
to? That's a logical question.
>> To the message of the third angel
combined with the me message that
Babylon has fallen.
Listen, please understand that Babylon
has fallen. Come out.
Well, if you're going to come out, where
you going to go?
>> Yeah,
>> that's the next logical question.
>> Going to be on your own. Obviously,
they must join the ranks of those that
make the call and proclaim the third
angel's message.
>> Yeah.
>> Join up with it.
>> Okay. Okay. All right. So, Martin, let
let's ask this question. Those that
actually now proclaim the message, come
out of Babylon, can they be part of
Babylon?
>> No. No. Because they're calling you out.
You're calling them out.
>> You're calling them out. So, they can't
be part of Babylon. You can't call you
something out that you're in. Right.
>> Can they have Babylonians in them? Yes,
>> we'll come to that in a moment. So, they
cannot be Babylon if they're calling
people out of Babylon
because you must be separate from
Babylon in order to call people out of
Babylon.
So, can there be Babylonians inside the
remnant? That was the next question.
>> Obviously, of course, there can be
Babylonians inside the remnant. Some of
them posing as remnant and someone not
knowing that they're Babylonians. Well,
they are in the remnant.
>> Why? Because the Bible warns of many
false brethren that were never part of
us.
So does this negate God's church because
there are Babylonians in it?
>> This is one of the best questions.
>> All right, let me ask a question.
In Israel of old, were the Sadducees and
Pharisees
>> Yes.
>> in it?
>> Yeah.
>> Did they actually join up with the
remnant at that stage?
>> No.
>> Some of them did.
>> Oh, you mean Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. like uh
individuals.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> The bulk of them did they?
>> No.
>> No. Okay. So why should it be any
different at the end? Right.
>> But they were still part of the church.
>> Okay. Does it negate the church? Of
course not. Because you will never leave
nor forsake her and the gates of hell
will not prevail against it.
>> And there's also weed and tears that
grow together.
>> They grow together. So these are couple
of I think logical questions. I just
want to mention that we I recently read
in Desire of Ages the chapter where the
wise men came from to Jesus's birth.
>> Wasn't it? It's actually the same that
you had there. The children, weren't
they studying?
>> They were studying
>> oracles.
>> Yes.
>> And the ones that were supposed to study
it wasn't ready for this.
>> No, they weren't ready. But these were
actually more informed than than the
others. In fact, they were surprised.
Where are you coming from? What are you
looking for? Where's this king you're
talking about?
>> Yeah.
All right. So, when you bring these
messages,
is this work associated with perils?
I'm sorry we're laughing, but definitely
no.
>> Some people say you're not allowed to
laugh.
>> Well,
it's a it's a what do you call that
laugh? It's a recognition laugh.
>> It's a recognition laugh. It's not a
haha laugh. It's uh if you if you it's
life is so serious.
>> Let's just let's just break out of this
for a second. All right. 2 Corinthians
11:26.
What were the tribulations of Paul who
actually comprised the remnant of Israel
of old? Right.
>> Yeah. That's actually very very well
put.
>> In journeyings, he was often in peril.
He was in perils in the water. He was in
perils by robbers. He was in perils by
his own countrymen. He was in perils by
the heathen. In perils in the city, in
perils in the wilderness, in perils in
the sea,
and then the worst one, the final cherry
on top, in perils amongst false
brethren.
I'm laughing because it's so true.
>> It's true. It's It's the truth. I mean,
yeah. Anybody who's who's anybody and
been part of the remnant church and you
really want to try and bring this
through through, you will acknowledge
that. Yes,
>> I must acknowledge that the greatest
perils that I've ever faced in my life
is the perils amongst false brethren.
But uh be that as it may,
>> that not that we condemn them.
>> No, I'm praying for them.
>> Absolutely.
>> Just pray for them. or Galatians 2:4.
And that because of false brethren,
>> unawares brought in who came in privy to
spy quietly, secretly
out our liberty which we have in Christ
Jesus that they might bring us into
bondage. Bondage to error.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. So, we have all of these
things duplicated today.
And then there's the question of an open
door that we read about in the church of
Philadelphia.
So we're trying to find out, you know,
how did this remnant come about? And
there was a process
through various stages of church
history. Prior to Philadelphia, you had
Sardis, which represents the Protestant
churches. So when this call came, you
know, come out of her or separate
yourselves from error,
some interesting things happened. So
let's pick it up there in Revelation
chapter 3. I know thy works. Behold,
I've set before thee an open door.
Now obviously that door must have been
closed before then, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So another's door opens
and no man can shut it.
>> Mhm.
For thou has little strength. Is it a
big group or a small group?
>> Little.
>> Small group.
>> Yeah.
>> And you have kept my word and has not
denied my name.
>> Are they word-based?
>> Remnant.
>> Are they Christ centered?
>> Yes.
>> Very important. They're word- based and
they're Christ centered. And there's an
open door in front of them.
>> And I will make them of the synagogue of
Satan. In other words, those that belong
to a church that Satan has sort of taken
over.
>> He's the new boss man in those churches
>> which say that they are Jews. We might
as well put Christians there.
>> And they are not.
>> But they're lying.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Now, who lies? Well, the Bible
says, "He who says he keeps my
commandments."
>> Yes. and do
>> that doesn't do it.
>> He's a liar and the truth is not in him.
Right.
>> Yeah.
>> I will make them to come and worship
before thy feet and to know that I have
loved thee.
So one cannot close the door of
utterance. One cannot stop the
proclamation though the gates of hell
try to shut it down. So if a message
comes and there's an open door through
which you must go and proclaim a new
message, then God is going to compel you
to go through that with that message.
John the Baptist preached in spite of
the consequences.
>> That's it.
Revelation 3:3 if we jump back a little
bit to where sad this was the message to
them which is Protestantism that stage
remember how they received and heard so
obviously they'd forgotten something is
there a commandment that starts with
remember
>> yes the fourth one
>> okay and hold fast and repent if
therefore thou shalt not watch
>> I will come on thee as a thief and thou
Thou shalt not know what hour I will
come upon thee. So there will be no
expectation of the coming of Christ.
>> Yeah. And it's interesting
uh those that do not watch will not know
the hour and will be caught off.
>> This Philadelphia group over here, do
you think they concerned themselves with
the doctrine of the coming of Christ?
>> Yes. Obviously, because this previous
group wasn't going to know about the
time or the hour, so they were never
preaching about it. So maybe this other
group was beginning to preach about it.
Is that logical?
>> Yes.
>> So a sealing message of the third angel
started like the rising of the sun from
the east and is now at its zenith
blazing its glory across the world. So
it starts small.
>> Mhm.
>> The message the paths are being
restored. you know, come back into
harmony with God's will.
And if we jump to Revelation chapter 7,
it says, "And I saw another angel
ascending from the east, having the seal
of the living God,
>> and he cried with a loud voice to the
fourth angel to whom it was given to
hurt the earth and the sea. Hurt not the
earth, neither the sea, nor the trees,
till we have sealed the servants of our
God in their forehead." So obviously,
there's some message here.
that has to be burnt into your mind
>> so that you cannot be moved from that
message.
And I heard the number of them which
were sealed. And they they were sealed
140 and 4,000 of all the tribes of the
children of Israel. Now, this is
obviously a number that we cannot
explain because the Bible doesn't
explain it,
>> but it's a symbolic number. And it
represents those that accept this truth.
>> And those that proclaim it must keep it
and not pollute it. Right.
>> Yeah.
Isaiah 56 verse 1-7, thus says the Lord,
keep ye judgment and do justice, for my
salvation is near to come, and my
righteousness to be revealed.
Blessed is the man that doeth this, and
the son of man that layeth hold on it,
that keepeth the
>> Sabbath.
>> Sabbath from polluting it,
>> and keepeth his hand from doing any
evil. Is Is there something important
about that verse?
>> For sure. The Sabbath is a very
important
portion of this whole message.
>> Okay.
It continues, "Neither let the son of
the stranger that has joined himself to
the Lord speak, saying, 'The Lord has
utterly separated me from his people.
Neither let the uno say, Behold, I am a
dry tree. For thus says the Lord unto
the unox,
and that keep my Sabbaths,
and choose the things that please me,
and take hold of my covenant, even unto
them will I give him my house, and
within my walls, a place, and a name
better than sons of daughters, I will
give them an everlasting name that shall
not be cut off. So, a a uno is someone
who has been emasculated.
So modern spiritually speaking,
has humanity been emasculated?
>> Yeah, definitely.
>> Yeah. No, it's totally
>> Yes. totally.
>> So, they have to be brought back.
>> Yeah.
>> And they're going to join God's people
and obviously they were not Sabbathke
keepers before, but they're going to
become Sabbathke keepers according to
this verse.
>> Yeah. and then through that be called
again sons and daughters of God.
>> Okay. Also the sons of the stranger
>> that join themselves to the Lord to
serve him and to love the name of the
Lord and to be his servants. Everyone
that keepeth the
>> Sabbath.
>> Why don't people get this?
>> Wow.
>> And taketh hold of my covenant. Even
them will I bring to my holy mountain
that is his kingdom. Yeah.
>> And make them joyful in my house of
prayer. Does he have a house of prayer?
>> No, for sure. He has to have one.
>> Their burnt offerings and their sac
sacrifices shall be accepted upon mine
altar. For mine house shall be called a
house of prayer for
>> all.
>> All people. So how many people must make
this mind switch?
>> Every single person.
>> Everyone.
>> So beautiful. So that your prayers, your
sacrifice to God will be accepted when
you fall into this place.
>> Correct.
>> But it's interesting that you in those
verses, the Sabbath, no wonder that
Jezebel brings him back to sun worship.
>> Yes. She's constantly pulling in the
other direction.
>> Yeah.
Jeremiah 23:6. In his day, Judah shall
be saved and Israel shall dwell safely.
and this is his name whereby he shall be
called the Lord our righteousness. So
there's no salvation by works here. It's
except the Messiah
and he will bring you back into harmony
with his will. But because you never
followed his will in the first place,
you have to be covered by his
righteousness.
In the 1846, Joseph Bates wrote his book
on the Sabbath. This is a very
interesting history.
Since then, the message has become
universal. The door indeed could not be
shut amidst all the efforts of the
enemy. They tried to keep this message
out, but it just wouldn't go away. It's
interesting that Bates only had 12 cents
in his pocket to start the work. and his
wife asked him please to go and buy some
provisions because there was no food in
the house left anymore
and he went and he bought food with
three of those pens.
>> What did he do with the rest?
>> He put down the money as a guarantee
that he would provide the rest once the
printing had was done. Yeah. But so he
bought provisions but the rest he used
>> to for printing his the book
>> for printing the book so that he could
feed people with it.
>> That's a that's a step of faith.
>> That's an interesting very interesting
story. All right. So indeed do not
despise the work of present truth and
its small beginnings. 12 p that's really
nothing. Nor should we forget Elder
White who sent out the pamphlets for
free from money earned by mowing a
field.
>> Yeah.
>> Wow.
>> Huh.
>> We can complain a bit early or easy.
>> Yes, we very easily complain. Amos 7:2.
And it came to pass that when they had
made an end of eating the grass of the
land, then I said, "Oh Lord God, forgive
I beseech thee. By whom shall Jacob
arise? for he is small.
>> So here was a very small group of people
this Philadelphia period that found an
open door discovered all of these things
used the means and the labor that was
which was all that they had
and set in motion a movement to restore
paths to dwell in and to restore
Sabbathkeeping.
Zechariah 4:10, for who has despised the
day of small things.
Because people always say, you know, who
who the heck do you think you are? Look
at this. We have all of these great
establishments, these wonderful
churches, these cathedrals, and you're a
bunch of miserable, povertystricken
people. Who Who are you? What can you
do? We hear that in the last one we did
on But they are such a small group here
in the USA.
>> Yes, they're so small group. They they
really have nothing to say. Didn't that
guy say that with that nice black beard?
>> For they shall rejoice and shall see the
plummet in the hand of Zerubbabel
with those seven. They are the eyes of
the Lord which run to and fro through
the whole earth. So Serubba Bell of
course rebuilding that structure, the
temple and everything that goes with it.
Restoring the truth.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Repairing the breach.
>> Or for verse 7. Who art thou, oh great
mountain before Zerubbabel? Thou shalt
become a plain, and you shall bring
forth the headstone thereof with
shouting, crying, grace, grace unto it.
The work starts small. There's always a
remnant that starts a great movement.
It's never a large crowd. 12 disciples,
one of them a traitor and the others
povertystricken little
>> fisherman.
Here's a quote from early writings and
it says, it was written in 1849. We had
a sweet and very interesting meeting
with the brethren at Toppson, Maine. The
Holy Ghost was poured out upon us and I
was taken off in the spirit to the city
of the living God. Then I was shown the
commandments of God and the testimony of
Jesus Christ relating to the shut door
could not be separated.
And that the time for the commandments
of God to shine out with all their
importance and for God's people to be
tried on the Sabbath truth was when the
door was opened and the most holy place
in the heavenly sanctuary where the ark
is in which contained the ten
commandments. This door was not opened
until the mediation of Jesus was
finished in the holy place of the
sanctuary in 1844.
Then Jesus rose up and shut the door of
the holy place and opened the door into
the most holy and passed within the
second veil where he now stands by the
ark where the faith of Israel was now
now reaches. So the ark stands for the
commandments. The commandment message
had to go out to the world.
>> Yeah. It had to become prominent
>> and not forget righteousness by faith in
the process.
>> Definitely. It's not a worksbased thing.
I saw that Jesus had shut the door of
the holy place and no man can open it
and that he had opened the door into the
most holy and no man can shut it. This
message is going to go to the ends of
the world.
God's commandments are the standard. No
human commandments are the standard.
>> So no one can shut it. and that since
Jesus has opened the door into the most
holy place which contains the ark, the
commandments have been shining out to
God's people and they are being tested
on the Sabbath question. Did we just
look at that from a biblical
perspective?
>> 100%. That's exactly the whole thing is
in harmony.
>> There's no disharmony here, right?
>> Shows what Philadelphia had to do and
here she just confirms it.
>> And the man with a nice black beard said
that if you do this, you're not a
Christian. Yeah.
>> Does that make any sense? If you want to
obey Christ rather than men, you're not
a Christian. You have to obey the church
rather than Christ.
>> The creeds
Heat.